let me tell you what i think may be the
most uh destructive and dangerous thing
this country has seen yet from cory bush
she's a newly elected i believe
progressive
she tweeted my first resolution in
congress will be to call for the
expulsion
of the republican members of congress
who incited this domestic terror attack
on the capitol
twenty thousand retweets how many
retweets
that'll go nowhere it's not about it's
not about that it's crazy what people
need to understand
you know when they were saying that mike
pence doesn't have the power or the
authority
it's about willpower we're human beings
we're not computer programs
what's to stop me right now from getting
up and just leaving
no people would be that's crazy tim left
his show and i was like he's not there
anymore he's got an empty chair
it's not likely to happen but i could do
it if i wanted to sure
mike pence could have walked out of the
building mike pence could have said
whatever whatever he wants
when corey bush says it's going to be a
resolution i think you're right probably
won't go anywhere
but think about the message being sent
now at a time of extreme
hyperpolarization i will expel
you i will try to remove you
she's like i'm part of the what are they
called that group of people yeah i'm
part of the squad now she's just this
like
this excessively radical uh
politician and and she's like all about
tribalism she wants to be part of this
group
and she wants to do this stupidly
radical uh
expulsion of sex listen there's more
hold on
she tweeted i'm calling for the removal
of every gop member involved in today's
coup
if you're with me sign your name to my
petition to send them a message that you
will not stand for their
treason do you want to know what my
biggest criticisms
this is a freshman congressman a
freshman congressman but listen
you know the problem is with lynn woods
saying mike pence committed treason do
you know the penalty for treasonous
death
death and when corey bush a sitting
member of the house who just got elected
is saying
that republicans should be expelled for
their treason
we are this is an escalation that is it
is is
it listen when i have been saying that i
see this coming and i see this
escalating
i'm not saying it should happen it
shouldn't happen and people need to stop
the problem is nobody wants to be
no nobody will accept the other side
de-escalating
at all they won't okay so corey bush is
not going to say i will be the person to
say
i'm calming down we need to learn to
work together and solve this problem
some have some have i think your chinese
finger trap metaphor is fantastic
because especially if me and you both
have our fingers in the trap if we're
not talking to each other we're not
gonna be able to coordinate
pushing in together to get out together
that's a really good analogy for the
tribalism
it's not just one person with their hand
stuck it's both stuck in the trap trying
to break out of it by pulling as hard as
they can
instead of talking it through calming
things down and working things out but
but the trap we're on the trap the trap
is social media the social media that
distributes images and videos and that
trigger your empathetic reactions
and sort you by tribe based on instinct
and gut so it's giving us tightening
impulses where we think the other
person's polling and when they're
actually not
algorithms and use organizations that
know if they get you in a fear state
that they get more clicks that they get
more revenue that they get more
engagement and they willingly
keep incentivizing these actions that
keep
bringing us at each other's throats and
here we are today
so and and and if you haven't already
smash that like button we
love your likes they really do help but
look i i have
i don't have to be an algorithm or a
news organization to to know what you're
saying is true
i can see it when i tweet about antifa
and antifa violence
mad engagement i tweet about positive
constructive things that you can do in
your life what is the alternative what
can we do what
medium engagement not nothing come on
come on but listen listen so so i really
do
genuinely just tweet what i think
randomly sometimes i'll see something
and i'll tweet about it right
here's funny thoughts so there's there's
a bunch of tweets that i'll post that'll
do really really well
but then a good example is when i
criticize the likes of lynne wood
and i get ratioed by people who are
critical or saying well let's wait to
see how things play out
i don't i don't care if people retweet
me or not i don't ask please retweet
this
i just tweet what i'm thinking sometimes
my thoughts resonate with people and
sometimes they don't
but there are a lot of people who
purposefully know what they're doing and
drive it
on purpose now many of these people like
to accuse me of doing that
it's just not true yeah i just i just
say what i think we also got some other
news so it looks like the the
the chair of cpac was wrong it wasn't a
16 year old
we're getting information from the new
york post that this was um
what specifically an air force veteran
that served in the military for 14 years
and had
done four tours of duty that passed away
and died
today from california tragic yeah that
sucks wow man
and you know the problem is a lot of
these people didn't know what they were
doing
they just didn't know any they didn't
know there was a video we were watching
um
i was watching it on twitter of this
woman and she's crying
and someone asks her you know what
happened and she goes i got amazed and
they were like
why did you get married she goes we
tried entering the building and i got
two feet in and then the police maced me
and they go why were you trying to get
in the building and she goes we're
storming the capital it's a revolution
she had no idea what she was talking
about she has no idea what they were
doing foot soldiers
stooges tools pawns okay
the street soldiers for antifa are pawns
into their network
do you think the network really cares
about those antifa scrubs
yeah i keep going i just don't want our
people used as pawns
as tools in 1800 getting into the
building would have
had value because that's where all the
paperwork was that's where the doc it's
not
on the internet now it's all stored in
servers in alaska
it's something you've been bringing up
in it's like why don't they just vote
remote and they probably are
we don't even know it they have tunnels
under they don't need to be in the
capital that building's point it's
ceremonial at this point
this is that other breaking news target
carlson just said that the cabinet is
considering invoking the 25th amendment
this is from carlson of fox news trump's
cabinet
um or or the new the new cabinet that's
the
that's the that's what i'm getting right
now is is that the group nancy pelosi
created or whatever
or is it trump's cabinet i'm not sure
i'm gonna listen so uh in dc
they wanted i mean there's so much we
haven't even got into the pipe bombs and
stuff we gotta talk about
uh i'll tell you what really freaked me
out you know what really freaked me out
jack
when virginia announced they were
sending in virginia national guard into
a federal jurisdiction
when maryland announced they were
sending in national guard into a federal
jurisdiction
at the request of the mayor no yeah
i know i saw the whole thing happen the
mayor requested virginia yeah because
the mayor requested the national guard
and the pentagon said no so then she
went and she requested local
jurisdictional help
there are fairfax county cops down there
they're montgomery county cops down
there
pence issued a statement ordering the dc
national guard to step up trump didn't
do it
wow this is what i i don't understand
why the national guard was rejected
there's a lot of confusing things for i
mean look first of all
last time there wasn't any damage like
this okay
and in in all the protests and riots
before it has been blm and antifa so
that's why there and
and the police force escalated as the
violence escalated and they finally
escalated the police force enough to to
put it down
maybe people just didn't assume that the
maga folks were going to come and and
from the capitol i said i do my segments
10 am 1 pm 4 pm
my 1 pm segment i'm like there's a lot
of people nothing's going to happen you
know i was like they're gonna trump
supporters don't do this stuff right
yeah they have little american flags
they're
they're in the ellipse they're they're
waiting for trump trump's gonna speak
he's gonna say his peace and they're
gonna leave
and then i remember like the video goes
up and then it was like 146 this woman
gets shot or whatever and i'm like my
video's been up for 45 minutes and i
said this wasn't gonna happen and it's
happening right now
you incited it so it's so insane that i
could say
two two things violence does not work
and i showed you the graph i showed you
black lives matter losing all their
support by writing don't do it and i can
say i don't even think trump supporters
will do it
i've been saying for the for the week
going up to it roads are being closed so
i don't know if i'm going to go there
anyway
and i don't think trump supporters are
going to do much
if anything you'd you would assume
people would say tim was discouraging
people from
going but it's this is the problem the
left and the right
uh to varying degrees don't care and
what i mean by that is
the left believes genuinely that the
right doesn't care and the right
believes genuinely the left doesn't care
and so both sides are unwilling to back
down
there's there's not going to be a
compromise on these issues and what
happens when you perpetrate one side
the other side gets even stronger and
then it just keeps going back and forth
and this continues oh well you know who
loves this is
the security apparatus they're they're
they're they're all sitting in their
private room
popping champions dude they're already
already drafting up their brand new
counter insurgency the task force for
the united states to go after
everybody the far right the worst threat
tweeted on a maga
hashtag it's coming it's coming this
this was
such a blunder i cannot emphasize this
enough
that they they were going to come after
us anyway the trumpification talk had
already begun there's no question
but now on the eve of them taking power
we have
literally we these guys storm the
capital have
handed the incoming administration
that's just the
free pass to crack down they will have
the full support of the american people
because hey there's a revolution going
on in in dc
got to put it down got to put down white
supremacists the worst national security
threat according to the fbi
bull and so now they're going to have
like basically
uh what do you call it when like a
mandate they have a mandate they will
have a mandate now
to crack down on people on speech on
everything else make everything worse
loughner on the house floor just said
quote when i arrived in washington this
morning
i fully intended to object the
certification of the electoral votes
however the events that have transpired
today have forced me to reconsider
and i cannot now in good conscience
object
so those are the comments that were just
issued okay so who who wins
the only winners here are the left
private security agencies oh yeah yeah
okay
so they they they won maga no one
nothing
nothing trump trump is
is they're talking about invoking the
25th what is that that's where you take
the acting president out
yep the vice president says he's unable
to do his job they remove him and i i
said earlier i would not be surprised
now
if they impeach and remove as like as
like an immediate and this is the
perfect opportunity to do it
look they claim trump was instigating
all this stuff trump
trump was definitely talking about the
evidence the election
was very energetic but he didn't tell
anybody to go do anything i was at the
speech it was dry
and what i what i noted was that he he
did talk about some dominion and last
minute vote switching and yada yada but
he
emphasized very concrete pieces of
evidence
matt brainard type evidence you know out
of state voters dead voters whatever
he's like i'm going to bore you with all
the details because he was there to lay
out his case
even pre-faced like please don't hate me
yeah when i'm so boring and then he
pretty much
put the ball in mike pence's court which
everyone was saying that was a pretty
weak move if you really
care he's like do the right thing you
wouldn't put all the responsibilities on
mike pence who publicly disagreed with
you on
this particular topic so he conceded in
front of everyone
today basically he said i'll never
concede but the speech was like
he gave the ball to mike pence right i
think that's fair to say right it's the
easiest way to be
like i'm not conceding it just pence
isn't supporting me i mean
let's be honest here he was already
planning on a golfing trip on the
inauguration
uh during uh you know scotland center
and scotland said no because of you know
covid
so there's also that important merit to
bring up here and people should also
understand
i think this is the uh i think it's i
think it's the end
do you disagree well no i was just
shaking my i don't know if i agree or
not but i was taking my head at the idea
that
this moment is the worst possible thing
that could happen to the emergent
trump nationalist populism that was
trying to form trying to come out of
this
stop the steal stop the steal could have
been literal could have been
metaphorical just the same way build the
wall was literal and
metaphorical pulling back from globalism
and you know erecting barriers in
general
stop the steal stop them from stealing
our government stop the critical race
there from taking over the government
stop the radical left from taking over
institutions
i can see that so there was like a seed
there's energy
and then something like this is bad bad
jews bad jews for the for the energy
uh jack i got bad news for you tell me
you're the number five
top trending uh hashtag is on twitter
right now
uh around to find out white privilege
white privilege white privilege oh
because
uh that white chick got shot for storm
in the capital uh probably because
they're what
what they've been saying is look what
happens when black lives matter protests
they get all these different ages
i mean look it's actually a fair point
but not necessarily for
entirely what they're saying they're
saying when black lives matter comes to
the to the capitol they go crazy with
mass security right
that's true they didn't do that this
time but guess who loses in the end
it's manga it's trump supporters well
trump wouldn't call in the national
guard he denied
the mayor nationals no no no no no no
no no the national guard said no
to the request are you sure they said no
yes
denied i mean i saw reports on twitter
and then the follow-on events
line up to me to to say that this was
likely to have happened
in that they went to the national guard
first no what and now they call it
cops from loudoun chris miller is
what i uh but chris miller reports to
trump so there's a whole lot that could
happen there what i heard was that
the national guard has already had
already been given orders on how they
were assisting local law enforcement
when the mayor came in and said we want
you to move they said that's got to go
through standardized procedure so we
can't do that
trump did not say give up
give them their request mike pence
eventually stepped in and said do it and
then they did so trump didn't do it yeah
there's so much fake news and nonsense
out there i mean i don't know if even i
should
address this uh specifically with what
keith oberman just said
oh no but you won't do it come on he's
left-wing we need to see both sides is
it about baseball we must know all sides
he said quote the united states of
america was today the victim of a
terrorist attack orchestrated by the
president of the united states today
donald trump's 9 11 attack on america
he's comparing what happened
yeah keith olbermann's 911. he reminds
me of that guy
in the french revolution remember that
writer the friend of the people i think
was
his news yeah he had a skin condition
he'd have to
and this woman stabbed him and martyred
him basically
yeah and caused so i like i mean i like
keith a little bit but
this rhetoric that he's been spewing the
last like he's five years since he went
crazy since he got kicked out of his uh
job his old job with
who was it msnbc when he got fired like
this was the
dumbest terrorist attack in the history
of terror attacks
a terror attack with a net result of
negative one dead
or a girl dead and your whole intent and
purposes being shot to [ __ ] all the same
time
what kind what is that that's why i
wonder about the police just letting
them in
i want to know more about that i'm going
to talk to my guys and see what they
have to say about that
they definitely there's videos of them
smashing the windows like the cops
weren't letting them in the building let
me see if i can but they smashed the
windows out they were climbing and
scaling those walls
we need to get those rivets out of the
walls by the way that you can
climb up yeah i've always thought about
that they walk by flat shear walls
so you can't get over them like who who
whoever was designing the capital they
were like
i think we need the ladder to get on to
get into the capital grounds here so
let's make this wall climbable what's
crazy let's make it look good no one is
going to have like a look it's got to
have those pigeon things on it so people
can't climb it you know what i mean
there's a little yeah
trump's banned from facebook for 24
hours yeah
yep twitter 12 hours this is the end of
of
trump's i think they're going to go
after them illegally
i know i think new york's going to try
to arrest him they're going to try and
shut down the organization
they they they did not want this man to
win and i tell you and
what we've seen here you know what i was
saying earlier when i said nothing's
gonna happen
i was like look we went through four
years of the left screaming trump's
illegitimate he didn't win
these scandals and i was like what's
what's the likelihood that we get the
same thing now with republicans saying
oh joe biden and scandals in ukraine
and that now we're seeing trump
supporters clashing with cops
like we saw with antifa i think it was i
said it was going to be like an
inversion this is not
this is something twisted and weird this
puts the
banning of enrique into a new light
doesn't it
why is that well because maybe he would
have been on the ground telling people
to chill the f
out i don't think he was going down into
dc thinking that they were going to
storm the capital
yeah in fights whenever you take down
the leadership the
the you know army usually is chaotic
doesn't know what these people are going
to be
shout out to john gary for that comment
on twitter
thank you very much and then uh another
thing i was thinking about today
is uh i noticed after the speech there
were just
gangs and i don't want to use okay let
me take that back
there were large groups of angry people
dressed in black
and they had shirts you know f antifa
then there was other group and they were
just marching around f and t v eventiva
and then another group and i'm not
disparaging these people are saying it's
wrong i'm just saying the energy was
different today
then there was multiple groups carrying
with you know like uh
football-sized uh flags american flags
all holding a piece of it over their
head walking down the streets chanting
who streets our streets who streets our
feet
we keep us safe exactly they stole all
the antifa chance i saw multiple groups
like that you see the
uh i heard reports that there were
leftists and conservatives chanting at
the police
i don't know if that's true though well
i'm telling you man my twitter mentions
yesterday went acap
like i couldn't believe it from trump
supporters yeah from my own people i
block a bunch of people i don't care
i think i think antifa is going to
become a a a
i don't want to say it's going to like
bipartisan isn't the right word but i
wouldn't be surprised like when you when
you when enrique tario tweeted that
proud boys are gonna dress like antifa
what's to stop now conservatives from
being like
okay yeah i think cerno uh tweeted this
afternoon this was
the birth of the right-wing antifa uh
john robb today tweeted out that uh this
was the
first the first uh mobilization for the
right-wing tribal network
uh he actually asked me yesterday dm's
how's mobilization looking
and i i didn't i couldn't tell him but i
saw it today man it's there the acab is
in effect
now i'm feeling it all over the place
the the the uh you know back the blue
seems to be history phase shift in the
network uh practically overnight had to
joe norman
on that one uh and then this violence
against the cops and storming in the
federal buildings i mean
like the whole environment shifted today
did you see the video
of i tell you the craziest thing i've
ever seen there's someone holding a thin
blue line flag
in front of a a and and right in front
of them in this huge crowd as a cop
being shoved and beaten by a bunch of
trump supporters
did you see that video no i don't know
if he was being beaten per se but he was
being roughed up
it's this um dragged out of the building
apparently this story of becoming the
demon that you
despise have you seen the watchman the
movie there's a cartoon in it where the
sky goes out to sea
and these these demons attack his boat
and take him and then
they're going to kill his wife back home
so he he he has these visions and
he just wants to kill this demon so he
finally you know he's sailing back to
save his wife and he's just obsessed
with destroying this demon he gets back
and it's nighttime and he's searching
for his wife
and he sees the demon and he kills it
and then he realizes when the light
comes on that
the demon was his wife and he became so
obsessed with destruction and destroying
this evil thing that
he became the evil thing what's the uh
what's the saying be careful when
fighting monsters lest you become one
for when you gaze into the abyss the
abyss gaze is back thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you